tanjiro kamado has many known powers and
abilities including water breathing
which he learns at the very beginning of
the story but also Sun breathing the
original and most powerful breathing
style Sun breathing was passed on from
father to son within tanjiro's family
for nearly 500 years but it was
transmitted in the form of a ritual
dance called the hinokami kagura tanjiro
Learned these elaborate dance moves from
his father but he eventually realized
that when combined with unnewton blade
these moves become a whole new breathing
style Sun breathing tanjiro also awakens
the Demon Slayer Mark he gains insight
into the transparent world he learns
repetitive action and a bunch of other
techniques and abilities he even shows
the ability to use Thunder breathing and
believe it or not he learns to use demon
powers if you want to know more about
tanjiro's full power including his
demonic abilities check out my full
video right now Link in the description
and in the pinned comment